grab your life jackets and VHS copies of
neverending story because we have the
biggest show about taking down Russians
since command oh wait that movie doesn't
involve Russians stranger things season
3 is back and with it a whole new ending
to unpack so in this video we're gonna
take a deep dive into what the hell
happened in Hawkins and what its events
could mean for season 4 so grab a breath
mint
because here we go the biggest shocker
for the end of the season is the
apparent death of Jim hopper but did he
actually die the show actually leaves a
few clues that hint at how and where Jim
might have gone Exhibit A as the
electromagnetic beam is about to explode
check out this shot this is right before
the Russians in their hazmat esque type
suits get vaporized no hopper Exhibit B
in episode 6 the Russian scientist
choice in hopper hold hostage alexei
gives some clues that may help bring
attention there are many of these before
the key he's referring to are these
big-ass laser beams aptly named because
they unlock the doors to other worlds
just like a key you're using this energy
emotions price was breakthrough to open
new to me a doorway a doorway between
worlds if there are many of these keys
as he calls them and they act as
channels between worlds is it not
possible then Hopper was somehow
transported to a the upside down or B
one of the other Russian facilities in
the post-credits scene we see the
Russians in Kamchatka seen here have
been successful at opening another one
of these portals after all how would
they have acquired this deme Gorgon but
it's what the russian soldier says here
that leaves the biggest unanswered
question no not the American the most
likely person behind that door is
hopper who likely got captured by the
Russians while he was in the upside down
or through some sort of teleportation
via the key of course Joyce doesn't know
that hopper could potentially be alive
in the last episode she tells him that
she might just stay in Hawkins even
agreeing to go on a full-on date with
him to Enzo's house your Chia - but with
him now gone in the town believing he
died in a tragic fire Hawkins has
nothing left for the buyers family it's
been nothing but a place of pain for
them and with choices only reason to
stay gone hopper it's time to move on
Joyce and hopper are also two characters
who share well-crafted character arcs
Joyce starts off the season unwilling to
move on with her life after the death of
her boyfriend Sam Gamgee I mean Bob
Newby she's still haunted by his death
and skirts hoppers advances even
forgetting to meet up for their date at
Enzo's she didn't even want to call it a
date contrast that to the Joyce we see
at the end she is the one to ask Hopper
out and literally moves on with her life
in a moving van hopper's arc however has
more to do with his relationship with
Elle
he's the overprotective father who
refuses to let his daughter grow up
going so far as to intimidate Mike maybe
by the end of it maybe if you're lucky
maybe I will continue to allow you to
date my daughter as hopper tells Elle in
his speech at the end his biggest fear
is change that shall one day change in
the girl he knew who used to eat Eggos
and laugh watching westerns with him the
girl that made him happy will one day
find someone else it's the fear that
many fathers go through but hopper can't
seem to let it go that is until the
final episode where he extends this
olive branch to Mike who's going to take
care of Elle be careful
Hopper's realizing he won't always be
there for her and his acceptance of mike
is a big leap from the hopper we saw in
episode one nod if you understand
l goes on her own journey this season
battling the main villain the mind
flayer and struggling with her own
relationship i dumped your ass like
hopper says she's a young woman who is
changing experiencing new things this is
encapsulated in episode 2 when Maxine
takes Elle out to experience the mall
it's like a child seeing candy for the
first time how do I know I like you just
try things on but besides navigating her
relationship with Mike the end of the
season sees a giant change for Elle both
externally and internally she's lost the
closest thing she has to a family hopper
as well as her power but is her power
gone for good
before the Battle of Star Court she
tells hopper that her power is like a
battery it just needs to be recharged
but three months later she still hasn't
regained her powers some theorized that
when L was bitten by the mine flare part
of the slug creature inside her sapped
her of her power but I don't necessarily
agree for one she was still able to
destroy the Russians by flipping over a
car after she was bitten so what
happened it's likely a combination of
two things one during the battle she was
likely spent of all her energy having
spent most of it in episode 7 fighting
off the mine flare and hoppers cabin
second we know that Elevens powers are
closely linked to her emotions in the
past she's used her powers when
frightened or angry three months later
we find her still struggling with the
most traumatic event of her life the
death of hopper
she's also moving with the buyers having
to say goodbye to her boyfriend and
starting a new life it's all extremely
stressful and no doubt has an impact on
her powers my guess is when L finds out
hopper is still out there
it will either help reignite her powers
or take her on a quest to rekindle them
but let's take a moment to talk about
the main villains of the season we have
the mind flayer Billy the Russians and
to a lesser extent mayor
klein near the end of the season the
kids discovered that the mind flayer a
creature from the upside down which took
control of will last season has been
trapped in Hawkins when L close the
portal at the end of the season but with
will no longer the host the mind flayer
had to look for someone new
eventually setting up shop at the
abandoned steel mill where he takes over
Billy's body for most of the season the
mine flare is too weak to fight Elle and
uses Billy to recruit more flares as
they're called to his side this includes
mrs. Driscoll and many of the
townspeople who eventually disintegrate
into piles of goo to morph into the mind
flayers physical form the only thing
stopping the mine flare from taking
complete control over the world is l
which is why Billy spends most of the
time saying he's referring to the giant
mine flare goop creature which gains
more and more strength as it acquires
more townspeople but we need to talk
about Billy breath struck last season I
hated him not because he was a villain
but because he seemed to be a dick just
for the sake of being a dick his actions
were thinly motivated as to why he
turned out the way he did in this season
however the writers have created an
empathetic Billy one haunted by the
trauma of his past which reveals why
he's such a dick in the first place when
L uses her special powers to delve into
Billy's memories which she's only used
once before with her mother last season
we get a better glimpse of what makes
Billy Billy she sees his mom and younger
self at the beach one of his favorite
memories which is juxtaposed with his
abusive father and him being taken away
from his mother as L ventures further
down this Beach the storm around her
intensifies as Billy's memories get
increasingly violent Billy lashes out at
others because it's his way of taking
out his childhood frustration he asserts
his power over others because he had no
power at home but Billy goes through a
redemptive arc at the end of the season
when he's about to kill L she talks to
him about his favorite memory of his
mother this allows him to break out of
the mind flayers control and save l at
the last minute sacrificing himself just
long enough for Joyce tiss shut down the
key and destroy the mine player for good
but this comes at a cost Billy's life
and honestly I thought this was a great
choice by the writers in the fan
community season 2 Billy was seen as one
of the most unlikable characters but now
they've done two things gotten rid of
him while actually making me care about
him it's a proper send-off to a
character who probably didn't have much
more to contribute to the show anyway we
also have the Russians who are the
narrative thread which linked the entire
season into the next not only does this
season start with the Russians it ends
with them too hinting that season four
will delve further into the u.s. versus
Russia Cold War undertones the Russians
are looking for ways to gain power and
assert dominance over the US and what
better way than harnessing the
interdimensional powers that these keys
seem to unlock as alexei said there are
many of these keys but that's only half
the equation
the other is location one of these
locations just happens to be Hawkins
Indiana another Kamchatka Russia if the
Russians could somehow weaponize the
deme Gorgons and or control the upside
down it may just be the thing that could
win the Cold War and finally we have
slimey mayor Cline played by the guy
from saw or Princess Bride if you want
something more uplifting Cline was
responsible for selling Hawkins land to
the Russians and ends up behind bars on
corruption charges so with the bad guys
defeated in our characters venturing off
in two different locations what does
this mean for season four first we have
the question of choice el Jon and will
leaving town it's never mentioned in the
show where exactly they're going but
it's far enough that Mike and Al can
only meet during the holidays so how
will this play out one theory suggests
that next season we'll see several
storylines set in different cities we
had one episode like this last season
where L ventured on our own in search of
her mother but this season would see
half the cast in Hawkins and half in a
yet unknown location Mike also says that
he'll have Dustin's radio hooked up so
they'll be able to communicate whenever
they want to and if two locations
weren't complicated enough we also have
hopper in Russia a second theory is that
some event will force el and the buyers
back to Hawkins and if there's any event
that would cause that it would likely
involve hopper and it's possible that
next season may take place entirely
during one of these holidays that way
we'd get all the characters back in
Hawkins without having to deal with them
hundreds of miles apart in the last
episode we also get a brief glimpse of
dr. Sam Owens who played a more
prominent role in season two
he's a high-ranking member of the US
Department of Energy who also is
responsible for helping hopper and
arranging the adoption of eleven the
fact that we see him for the last
episode after being non-existent this
entire season hence that season four
will likely involve the US government as
the plot of the Russians has now been
discovered and covered up by the US
government now I could do a whole other
video on all the other characters and
their arcs during the show especially
our beloved dusty buns but in this one I
just wanted to cover the main points
involving the ending however if you want
more stranger things videos shoot me a
comment or send me a message on Twitter
Epting story YT make sure to LIKE and
subscribe I have more videos on the way
and remember daddy loves you very much